patients who have been infected with the
corona virus and have recovered could be
the key to fighting the disease one
potential treatment uses the antibodies
built up in the blood of patients who've
had the illness dr. Jon LaPook shows us
how testing is already underway what
we're doing is monitoring these patients
very closely this past weekend dr. Eric
Salazar supervised the treatment at
Houston Methodist Hospital he hopes will
become the first proven therapy against
kovat 19 here's how it works
blood taken from recovered patients
contains antibodies that can attack the
virus dr. Salazar and his team
transfused plasma the part of blood
containing those antibodies into two
critically ill patients have you
discussed that goal for how many people
you'd like to be able to treat a day
using this method as many as possible
dr. Salazar is watching closely to see
if the transfusion works it may have
helped in a small number of patients in
China but much more study is needed
kindergarten teacher Julie Thaler a
Kovan 19th survivor has donated her
blood to possibly be used in a similar
transfusion in New York City I am one of
the survivors
it's a tough ride I got very lucky and
it was a way that I could give back a
lot of its gonna depend on you know the
donor pool dr. Nicole Bouvier and her
team at New York's Mount Sinai will soon
be using the same treatment just
performed in Houston why do you think
this might work we have some idea
partially from the 1918 influenza
pandemic that taking blood plasma from
one person and giving it to another
actually may improve outcomes antibodies
against coronavirus are not only being
used for treatment they also help
identify people who may have been
infected without knowing it can
aggressive testing regimen with our
frontlines to find out you know who has
levels of immunity is an opportunity to
get back to the new normal as quickly as
possible
Lou Reese and May Mayhew or co-ceos have
United biomedical an international
biotech company they're one of several
companies to develop a simple rapid
blood test for kovat 19 antibodies to
see if someone has been infected and
built up immunity to the virus their
current plan tests as many of the
residents of Colorado's rural San Miguel
County as possible how many people do
you think you'll be testing there's just
under 8,000 in the county we'll be able
to find out who's been exposed and who
has antibodies and hence who has a
certain level of immunity to this once
the antibody test is more widely
available researchers will be able to
screen large numbers of potential donors
for antibody rich plasma to be used for
treatment I don't think any Center
across the country is gonna have any
trouble recruiting donors that have
recovered from Kobe 19 these are
incredibly generous people and dr. Jon
LaPook joins us from home now John why
is it so important to do widespread
antibody testing Anthony you know it's
very likely that there are a lot of
people out there who have been infected
with the new corona virus but had little
few or maybe no symptoms at all and this
is going to help us to get our arms
around it I mean this is hugely
important think about it if it turns out
that those people have some immunity
some protection because of these
antibodies now depending upon
how much protection they have maybe they
could go back to the frontlines again
and we can get we won't have to make
this choice between do we stay do we
save the economy or do we save the
healthcare system there are a lot of
questions here you know how protected
our people how long will the immunity
last there are a lot of questions and
love fewer answers right now John how
soon after patients get these plasma
treatments
well we actually know if it's working
you know in China there was a report of
just five patients in China who had this
done and they had other therapies so
it's hard to really know over the next
week or two they seem to get better but
again we don't know if it was the
antibody treatment or other medications
they were getting in the past back in
1918 and then the pandemic flu there was
some success and there are sporadic
cases here and there but there's never
been a huge controlled trial to see
exactly how this works and in what
people it works and for how long it
lasts and things like that so this will
be an opportunity to do that Anthony all
right still something promising dr.
Chawla Pook thanks John